hopefully at this point you've got a
decent absolute value a decent bounty
looking absolute value graph okay you
can see I've got an a y-intercept of
three where did I get that from yeah
very good when I put in x equals zero
for y equals this you just get that well
this is in the form a nice form right y
equals MX plus C's are there there's the
intercept right there we talked before
if you remember mrs. Lee's told you a
nice quick way to find the cusp right
you can just directly calculate it how
do you do that where do you where do you
look yeah listen yeah if you make the
inside of the absolute value if you make
that if you set that equal to zero and
then solve you will come up with x
equals negative one and a half and that
is where it's going to bounce okay so
that's great then you can see I've got
my positive part my negative part and
I've labeled them accordingly then I'm
sort of like oh I have my graph how do I
use this thing what I'm trying to find
oops wrong color I'm trying to find
first where does it intersect with this
guy that's this value that I have over
here okay so I've got a point here and a
point here and I'm tracing down okay now
we we were handing out those rulers
before because in this case if you're
solving something visually you have to
be able to rely visually on what you've
done has to be accurate enough you can
say oh I know what those solutions are
okay you can of course sort of rely on
your algebra but this picture is what we
want to rest on has anyone found these
two values anyone got them yeah go ahead
can you give us both of them minus five
and two do we have some agreement there
yeah okay so we've got one of them and
then you can check the other one in
confirm okay and one of the great things
about doing this graph and I know like
at the beginning it takes a long time to
assemble this thing but you will get
better and better at it with practice
one of the great things about this is I
can eyeball this and I can say of course
there's the values that I would expect
right like if I accidentally got a value
like negative two suppose I just did my
algebra and I've got a value of negative
two looking at this I'm like that can't
be right negative two would be somewhere
like here right so my graph is of a
sufficient quality that I can actually
use it to do a sense check on my answers
right negative five and two
they look they're in exactly the right
spot okay so now we come to the final
part right what did you an hour
something did you get different values
yeah ninety four point five and two
point five can we get a check yeah yeah
can we get a check on did anyone else
get can we confirm as anyone else got
solutions to this if we if we don't have
anyone else did you want to ask a
question or did you wanna suggest an
answer say it again okay so let's let's
see if we can confirm this right when
you are not sure oh my graph is kind of
rubbish or I was in a hurry right then
you can rest on your edge where is
nothing wrong with that okay so to find
this value over here I will be solving
when 2x plus 3 is equal to 7
yeah that's when this part here which is
2x plus 3 and Zack he actually asked a
really good question before I have you
might have noticed I've labeled the two
branches with different equations rather
than labeling the whole thing with one
equation part of the reason I did that
is to make this algebraic check easier
right because I know this parts the 2x
plus 3 part in this part to the minus 2x
minus 3 part okay so when I go ahead and
solve this can someone tell me what I
should do to both sides what can help me
to get toward making X the subject yeah
I could subtract 3 from both side so
I'll go ahead and do that that gives me
4 and then I'm going to divide by 2 so
that confirms for me that this answer is
okay and I think you can probably extend
that and you see it's going to be fine
right so it's always important to check
there because I can't tell the
difference visually between 2 and 2 and
a half and look mmm but I don't sure
right
so using algebra is okay
like it's so great question when in the
Equality sign here come from when I had
inequalities here rasa I'll come to your
question in a second well unless you
want to take it so related yeah can you
go ahead that's a great question so can
I solve this part is greater than equal
7 and then can I solve this part is
greater or equal to 7 the short answer
is yes you can but I can use my graph to
not have to worry about like sometimes
you will get confused about which way to
my inequalities go do I have or or and
what do I do with that right I'm gonna
use my graph so I don't need to think
about that extra algebra okay now came a
trans question like why is this an equal
sign we're not hating equalities before
right this is an equal sign because I'm
trying to find a point I'm trying to
find like where is that precisely when
is this thing exactly equal to 2 once I
found that point I can use it to answer
the original question which is the
inequality that's not about to do okay
yes yes so in fact you said it perfectly
sorry my equations they back up they
confirm they check what I have here on
the graph and so they're kind of like X
you're working if you like to make sure
it wasn't just me making it up or I
didn't just have like a phony looking
graph I can confirm its I can I've got
proof that's accurate okay all right
did you wanna ask a question do join us
oh okay all right well let's go through
this process again but you it's okay
yeah it's okay well we'll get there so
if I've checked it for 2x plus 3 I want
to check it for minus 2x minus 3 as well
that's the other branch can you see that
so let's give this again minus 2x minus
3 equals 7 that's where that point is
okay so what can I do to both sides of
the equation
I'm gonna add 3 it's pretty much emerges
once you've done that right you're like
if I add 3 I get 10 and then my next
line will be x equals negative 5 okay
all right bless you
we're all we're all having the sniffles
okay he
my grave I'm gonna use this to mark the
part on the graph you know how I said oh
when does this graph when is it I
started rubbing off a didn't finish
when is it below this line well I'm not
asking about below on this question M I
see this in equality what does it tell
us when am I
yeah greater than that's above okay so
I'm going to mark it and if you have a
highlight or something like that that's
fine I'm gonna mark in the parts that
are above you know okay so these are the
parts that I want and so now I just need
the x values that go with that yeah
Rastan to write this algebraically you
would actually have to stay okay he's a
case for this guy then solve and then
here's a case for this case to and then
solve okay oh oh like the bird like if I
wanted to solve underneath I would
switch the direction of this so I would
say something like the absolute value of
2x plus 3 is less than equal recept that
means below whereas this means above
that okay yeah this part here oh you're
asking what my answer is yeah okay I was
just getting to that
so let's have a think right I want to
know the X values that express this part
over here and this part over here you
can see it's to the left of this spot
and to the right of this spot in fact if
I put full circles here I've actually
just drawn the solution on the number
line right but I do need to state this
algebraically so how do I do that well I
want to state this as to the left of
negative five so how do I say that X is
less than or greater than less event do
I include the boundary
I do include the boundary over here I
excluded because I didn't have it in the
question but here I do have it in the
question so if I include here then I'm
going to include here as well so less
than negative 5 or X is going to be
greater than that's this part over here
positive 2
that's the algebraic statement for the
sake of completeness I feel like we
should write the interval notation as
well but as you can see because I
actually have two intervals not one this
is a bit Messier so unless they asked
you to unless they forced you to I would
not use interval notation this but we
totally can we can say X is going to
belong in I'm going out from left to
right where am i where am i starting
over here negative infinity and as a
consequence can I ever get to negative
infinity
no I can't say well I use a square
bracket no it's gonna be a parenthesis
right I go all the way from negativity
and I stop at negative five and that's a
square square bracket because it is
included right and then I say oh I've
got to have this thing as well do
remember this symbol it's a it's a U for
union right it wait on a second all
right the negative five
oh you mean joke about this okay I'm
gonna come to that question in a minute
let me finish the answer and then I'll
tell you why actually is the Union do I
include two or not a juicer there's a
square bracket there and then I go all
the way off to to infinity and beyond
hooray there we go okay now the question
that was asked for us wait do I do am I
supposed to do that one right that's the
intersection okay say that again
ah so this is end right this is or now
the reason why it's supposed to be or is
can you tell me a number that is both
less than negative 5 and also
simultaneously greater than 2 can you
think of a number that does that the
answer is nor you can think about what
number that does this all that but it
can't do both at the same time which is
the word and/or this symbol here so
because like there are no numbers that
do that and I actually want some numbers
that is not the symbol that I will use
it is a bit tricky
all right does anyone have any questions
on that do you see how we use the graph
recen okay do we not carry out the way
though the short answer is no and the
reason why is if you have a look back at
the original question how many Y's do
you see in the original question no wise
right we actually used the Y's to help
us graph this and that helps us solve
the X's the X's are the things I'm
really after okay